INTO TONIGHT, BUT YEAH, TUCKER,
PEOPLE WANT TO BE OPEN AND ARE
BEING LOUD.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
>> Tucker:>> Tucker: WELCOME TO
"HANNITY" BREAKING NEWS ON
MULTIPLE FRONTS TONIGHT.
THE PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING LOUD AND
CLEAR AND REOPENING OF AMERICA
WITH THE SUN STATES LIKE IT OR
NOT WELL UNDERWAY.
THE BUSINESSES ARE OPENING THE
SAFETY MEASURES AND PLAYS.
NASCAR IS BACK, GOLF IS
BEGINNING TO COME BACK IN THE
RATINGS ARE MASSIVE.
WOW WONDER WHY.
MAJOR PROGRESS IN THE RACE FOR A
VACCINE.
A BIOTECH GIANT, MODERNA SINGH
PROMISING RESULTS.
HUMAN TESTING ACTUALLY CREATING
ANTIBODIES.
WE WILL TALK MORE ABOUT IT.
ALSO, WE WILL REVIEW THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE SUCCESSES OF
FLORIDA, TEXAS, THE FAILURES OF
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, MICHIGAN.
PLUS WE WILL REBUILD THE
COUNTDOWN OF ALL COUNTDOWNS.
LET’S JUST SAY IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE EVER SO FORGET THE JOE BIDEN
IN IN HIS BASEMENT.
WE WILL HAVE THE LATEST FROM HIS
CAMPAIGN AND WE WILL ALSO LAY
NEW SOUND FROM THAT PHONY
HYPOCRITE BARACK OBAMA.
IT WILL MAKE YOUR BLOOD BOIL
BECAUSE HE’S REALLY DESCRIBING
HIMSELF.
AND WE START TONIGHT WITH GOOD
NEWS.
WE ARE SEEING MAJOR ADVANCEMENTS
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A VACCINE
FOR COVID-19.
THIS BIOTECH COMPANY, MODERNA,
HUMAN TRIALS ARE YIELDING
EXTREMELY POSITIVE RESULTS THIS
EARLY, BUT MODERNA CEOs HAVE
THE INITIAL STUDY COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ANY BETTER APPEAR AT THE
TRIAL VACCINE IS SAID TO BE
GENERALLY SAFE AND WELL
TOLERATED AMONG PARTICIPANTS WHO
RESPONDED TO THE VACCINE BY PROD
A HIGH NUMBER OF ANTIBODIES
WITH A RELATIVELY LOW DOSE.
WE WILL EXPLAIN.
ALSO A VACCINE MAY NOT BE A LONG
WAY OUT, BUT IT IS A TERRIFIC
DEVELOPMENT FROM THE TOP
SCIENTISTS.
WE KNOW THEY WILL GET US OUT OF
THIS AND ANY OTHER PANDEMIC WE
HAVE.
OTHER GOOD NEWS, AMERICANS HAVE
DECIDED THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
REOPENING.
THEY ARE TAKING MATTERS INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THIS IS THE AMERICAN BRILLIANCE,
INGENUITY, CREATIVITY AT ITS
BEST.
HAIR SALONS REOPENING WITH THE
USE OF MASKS AND OTHER PPE.
LOOK AT THIS WITH CASINOS.
THEY ARE LITERALLY CONSTRUCTING
CLEAR-CUT BARRIERS THAT ENABLE
GAMBLERS WITH 6 FEET DIFFERENCE,
SOCIAL DISTANCING TO RETURN TO
THE TABLES THERE.
THEY ALSO LAUNCH SHIELDING
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS WITH
PLEXIGLASS AND, OF COURSE,
GLOVES AND MASKS.
IN NEW JERSEY CONDUCTING
MANDATORY TEMPERATURE CHECKS.
THIS GYM WITH A STATE LOCKDOWN
ORDER IN NEW JERSEY AND
REOPENING ALL THE WAY, BUT AS
YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE, THE STATE
MANDATES ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE MEANINGLESS FOR THE PEOPLE
NOT LISTENING.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE MADE UP THEIR
OWN MINDS.
AND IT’S NOT AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE GOVERNORS THAT PARTICULARLY
AN AWFUL JOB.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY ARE AND WERE.
WE PLAN -- >> NORMALLY YOU ARE
ALL IN THE VIOLATION OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
ON THAT NOTE, HAVE A GOOD DAY.
EVERYBODY BE SAFE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: THAT ONE GYM IN
NEW JERSEY AS ONE OF MANY
BUSINESSES FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
THE STATE LOCKDOWN SINCE THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN, YEAH YOU
CAN’T CUT YOUR LAWN FOR A WHILE.
MEDICAL CENTERS, THEY HAVE NOW
SUED GOVERNOR WHITMER WITH HER
BAN ON MEDICAL SERVICES THAT SHE
DEEMS NONESSENTIAL.
KENTUCKY’S DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
SUED FOR RESTRICTING CHURCH
SERVICES, EVEN WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MASKS.
FOLLOWING A STUDENT IN THE GREAT
STATE OF WISCONSIN, THEY ARE
SUPREME COURT STRUCK DOWN IT’S
SAFE AT HOME MANDATES.
BY THE WAY, CALIFORNIA BEGINNING
TO FACE DOZENS OF LAWSUITS OVER
CONSTITUTIONAL INFRINGEMENTS.
WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING IS THE
BEGINNING TO THE END OF THE
STATE LOCKDOWN’S.
IT LOOKS LIKE PEOPLE WATCH, THEY
LISTEN, THEY QUARANTINE COME
WITH A SHELTER IN PLACE, AND
THEY DECIDED WHERE THE RISKS
ARE.
AND TONIGHT, WE KNOW WHAT IT
WILL TAKE.
WE LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS FROM
STATES, AND A LOT OF BAD LESSONS
FROM OTHER STATES.
WE LEARN FROM THICK SUCCESS IN
FLORIDA AND TEXAS.
THEY HAVE ISOLATING AT RISK
COMMUNITIES, NURSING HOME
LONG-TERM CARE FACILITIES,
RETIREMENT HOMES.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREENS.
THESE ARE THE STATS FROM FLORIDA
AND TEXAS.
THE COMBINED POPULATION OVER
50 MILLION RESIDENTS INCLUDING A
HUGE ELDERLY POPULATION.
THIS TO STATES INCLUDED FOR
4,000 TOTAL DEATHS.
ABOUT 80,000 TOTAL CASES.
FAR LEFT OF THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN BY COMPARISON, YOU CAN
SEE THE STATE OF NEW YORK
REPORTED 340,000 CASES,
APPROXIMATELY 30,000 DEATHS,
SOME 30% OF THOSE COMING FROM
NURSING HOMES.
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF ISOLATING
NURSING HOMES LONG-TERM CARE
FACILITIES LIKE THEY DIDN’T
FLORIDA AND THEY DID IN TEXAS,
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER PURITY IS WAS
MARCH 25TH, FORCING THESE
NURSING HOMES TO ADMIT COVID-19
POSITIVE PATIENTS.
AROUND 30% OF THE DEATH TOLL IS
FROM THESE FACILITIES.
AND DESPITE ONLY RECENTLY
WITHDRAWING THIS DISASTROUS
ORDER, ANDREW CUOMO IS TOTALLY
UNAPOLOGETIC.
IMAGINE IF TRUMP SAID THE
FOLLOWING.
>> OLDER PEOPLE, VULNERABLE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DIE FROM
THIS VIRUS.
THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
DESPITE WHATEVER YOU DO, BECAUSE
WITH ALL OF OUR PROGRESS AS A
SOCIETY, WE CAN’T KEEP EVERYONE
ALIVE.
AND DESPITE WHAT EVERYONE YOU
EVERYTHING YOU DO.
AN OLDER PEOPLE ARE MORE
VULNERABLE.
>> Sean: IN SPITE OF WHAT YOU
DO, COVID-19, LET’S SEND THEM
INTO THE AREAS WHERE THE PEOPLE
ARE THE SICKEST AND MOST
VULNERABLE.
THAT WAS A DUMB IDEA.
IMAGINE IF PRESIDENT TRUMP THEN
SAID THAT.
DESPITE WHATEVER YOU DO, WELL,
IF YOU DID WHAT FLORIDA DID AND
YOU DID WHAT TEXAS DID, YEAH,
THEY DID A LOT BETTER.
BUT ANYWAY, DESPITE WHAT YOU DO
COME OKAY, LIKE FORCING NURSING
HOMES TO TAKE IN PATIENTS INFECT
WITH CORONAVIRUS WHEN THEY WERE
AND THE SCREENING ON PREPARED
AND INSTEAD OF ADMITTING THEM TO
THE USNS COMFORT OR THE
JAVITS CENTER, THEY WILL LOSE A
THOUSAND OF 3,000 BEDS THERE AND
ONLY 182 BEDS ON THE HOSPITAL
SHIP.
WELL, GUESS WHAT THEY REMAIN
LARGELY UNUSED.
GOVERNOR CUOMO, MURPHY OF
NEW JERSEY.
THEY MADE THE DUMBEST DECISIONS
THEY DID NOT PROTECT THE ELDERLY
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE.
FLORIDA AND TEXAS DID APPEAR
THOSE EXECUTIVE ORDERS BY THESE
FOUR STATES THAT FAILED HELPED U
LEARN WHAT NOT TO DO.
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, AND NOW
DEMANDING RED STATES ALSO PAY
OFF THEIR MASSIVE DEBT.
THE TWO STATES THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST INCOME TAXES IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, THEY ARE SOMEHOW
DROWNING IN DEBT.
FOR COMPARISON, FLORIDA AND
TEXAS NO INCOME TAX AND BY THE
WAY NO DEBT AND THEY MANAGED TO
BALANCE THEIR BUDGET.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, RESPONSIBLE
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN RED STATES
IN NO WAY SHOULD YOU BE FORCED
TO PAY OFF THE UNFUNDED
PENSIONS, SYNC WITH -- MASSIVE
ENTITLEMENTS, RECKLESS WASTEFUL
SPENDING ON NEW GREEN DEAL
NONSENSE, HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF WASTE.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THAT
WITH TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND A
SECOND.
BUT FIRST WE TURN TO MORE
BREAKING NEWS FROM THE PRESIDENT
WHO JUST ANNOUNCED HE HAS BEEN
TAKING HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AS A
PROPHYLACTIC TREATMENT TO
PREVENT COVID-19 FOR OVER A
WEEK.
PREDICTABLY, THE MOB, THE MEDIA
AT THE NOW HYPERVENTILATING OVER
THOSE REMARKS EVER SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MENTION WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WHERE
POSSIBLE BENEFITS MONTHS AGO,
THE MOB, THE MEDIA, THEY HAVE
BEEN WAGING WHAT IS UNHINGED,
NONSTOP NEVER-ENDING P.R.
CAMPAIGN AGAINST HIM.
THEY ACT LIKE THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS HOPE AND OPTIMISM ABOUT THE
DRUG WERE SOME TYPE OF MORTAL
SIN.
THEY CALLED HIM RECKLESS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE.
THAT WOULD BE YOUR FELLOW
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS.
THEY SCREWED UP.
TRUMP BUILT THE HOSPITALS,
MANNED THE HOSPITALS AND SENT
ALL THE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT THEY
NEEDED.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAS MADE A
DECISION ALONG WITH THE DOCTORS
TO TAKE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AS A
PREVENTATIVE TREATMENT.
OF COURSE, THIS DRUG IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE COVERED
EXTENSIVELY ON THE PROGRAM.
IT HAS BEEN TREED TO TREAT
MALARIA, LUPUS, RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS FOR YEARS AND NOW A
POTENTIAL TREATMENT FROM A
POTENTIAL PROPHYLACTIC ON
CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE SO FEW
PATIENTS WITH LUPUS AND
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS WERE
CONTRACTING COMPANY THEY DO.
ONE EXPERT PROBABLY THE WORLD’S
EXPERT ON HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS
A RENOWNED BOARD CERTIFIED
RHEUMATOLOGIST, CEDARS-SINAI
MEDICAL CENTER, HIS NAME AFTER
42 YEARS OF PRACTICE, DANIEL
WALLACE HAS TREATED THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS WITH LUPUS, RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS, ET CETERA SINCE 1985.
HE ISSUED A LETTER RECENTLY AND
FAILED TO TREATMENT READING
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS A VERY
SAFE DRUG.
IT HAS BEEN GIVEN TO TENS OF
MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
WORLD SINCE ITS APPROVAL IN
1955.
THAT IS 65 YEARS AGO.
42 YEARS OF PRACTICE, NO PATIENT
OF MINE HAS EVER BEEN
HOSPITALIZED FOR ANY
COMPLICATIONS.
AND THIS DOCTOR HAS OFFERED FOR
PEER REVIEW OF STUDIES AND
AUTHOR OF TEXTBOOK ON "LUPUS."
DOSES IN A TIME FRAME WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AS IT RELATES TO
TREATMENT OF COVID-19.
I’M NOT A DOCTOR.
I’M NOT ADVISING YOU TO TAKE THE
DRUG, BUT THAT GUY WITH THOSE
CREDENTIALS, HE SEEMS LIKE THEM
BEST EXPERT IN THE COUNTRY.
IT WOULD TAKE HIS WORD FOR IT.
YOU CAN STAY INFORMED, KNOW THE
RISK, CONSULT YOUR DOCTOR AND
YOU ULTIMATELY DECIDE.
DESPITE WHAT THE MOB AND THE
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE, AMERICANS ARE
SMART PEOPLE.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THE LIES,
HYSTERIA, CONSPIRACY THEORIES
COMING FROM THE MEDIA EVERY
SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY
24-HOUR DAY.
THE AMERICANS ARE SICK AND TIRED
OF THIS B.S.
ONE LOCAL REPORTER FROM
LONG ISLAND CAPTURED ALL OF THIS
ON HIS TWITTER LIFE FEED AND IT
DID NOT GO PARTICULARLY WELL FOR
HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> GO HOME!
>> YOU ARE THE ENEMY OF THE
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE THE ENEMY!
>> YOU ARE CONFUSED.
>> TELL THE TRUTH, COME ON!
[CHANTING]
>> FILM XP WHEN I THINK PEOPLE
ARE ALLOWED TO SPEAK OUT IN
AMERICA, SOME PEOPLE GET
UPSET WHEN AMERICANS SPEAK OUT.
IT IS HARD TO BE SYMPATHETIC TO
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA MOB
CONSIDERING ALL OF THE MOB DOES
IS THINK THAT AMERICANS, WELL,
RESPECT THEM, BUT AFTER YEARS
AND YEARS OF LIES AND SLANDER
AND HOAXES AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ON THE YEAH, THEIR
CREDIBILITY IS ZERO.
REMEMBER DOZENS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RALLIES.
REMEMBER THE PEOPLE IN THE
CROWD.
THEY WERE PRETTY LOUD AND CLEAR
WITH THEIR CRITIQUES, BUT THEY
THINK OF FAKE NEWS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO BAD AND SO PATHETIC AND
THE RATINGS ARE GOING DOWN.
BOOZ[BOOS]
[CHANTING]
>> Sean: CNN SOCKS!
THAT WAS PRETTY LOUD.
AND IT HAPPENED A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
WHY?
THEY’RE FAKE NEWS, THEY DO SUCK
AND HAVE A POLITICAL AGENDA.